and as we turned into the entrance to
the er
we looked at each other and
i think kathy was the one who said
in this moment
like our lives are changing forever
you and kathy have a new book that just
came out the defining the defining
moment how writers and actors build
characters
great and we're wondering if there are
certain chapters or a portion of the
book that you can reference first off a
moment or moments that damage or [ __ ]
a character do you have any references
we do because that's
uh that's something that
is
critically important
in storytelling because we're so often
dealing with characters who are damaged
or crippled
so
kathy and i talk about
from the film finding nemo the way
nemo's dad marlin
is damaged by the tragic loss of his
family to a barracuda
but we also
try to
share some of our own defining moments
because we urge
storytellers
writers actors directors to
delve into their own histories
to find the moments that have defined
them in this case moments that have
damaged
wounded crippled them
in the history of our family
when we think of defining moments
there's one moment that
stands above all the others and it was
the moment when
uh our son peter as a five and a half
year old little boy
was diagnosed with a brain tumor
and
our pediatrician
put the mri films in our hands and said
you need to drive to ucla medical center
a brain surgeon will be waiting for you
and
he'll explain everything
and
so kathy and i got in the car and oh and
the doctor said and don't stop anywhere
on the way
so we put our son in the car
drove to the er
and as we turned into the entrance to
the
er we looked at each other and
i think kathy was the one who said
in this moment
like our lives are changing forever
and that was true
we now in in our family talk about the
moment before peter got sick
and we talk about the moment after
peter's brain tumor
my daughter's life experience
was different from that moment on
uh
her
best friend
um and brother
suddenly was
out of her life and in the hospital and
she wasn't seeing him and
when she did finally see him after
surgery he was changed
the tumor was gone
but he didn't speak
didn't
walk
he looked to her
like a monster
and
for peter that was a defining moment it
was a moment that crippled him that made
him and peter
many years later is alive
but as a result of the surgery
radiation
which isn't good for little boys brains
and chemotherapy
he's kind of a real-life forest gump
uh pure of heart
and
um
and
he knows what love is
and he struggles
um intellectually
so
that was a moment of
wounding for him
it was the beginning of the death
of the dreams
that we had for him
we had to find new dreams to replace the
ones that died
and it took a long time though
we were the ones who were dragged
kicking and screaming
to
recognizing
the dreams that were not going to happen
now for him
even as we approached his 16th birthday
and
people his age were going to get
driver's licenses
none of us wants to live in a world
where peter reilly has a driver's
license because he just cannot process
all of the information fast enough and
he would get it right
95 percent of the time but that's not
that's not enough
on the streets of la
and so i had to
eventually say to him peter
you're not going to get a driver's
license
and so he's found a new dream he heard
about the google car and so he's all
about a self-driving car as soon as he
can get one he wants a car that's going
to take him wherever it can take him
we had to absorb
a lot of
of losses
but a day came when
peter had struggled along in school got
to high school
and
in california there's
a test you have to pass in order to get
a diploma
called the california high school exit
exam it's a standardized test so no
matter how much people at the school
loved him
and helped him
[Music]
there was no way he was going to get a
diploma if he didn't pass this
test
and i remember the day that the results
came in the mail and
uh i just heard kathy screaming in the
other part of the house she'd open the
envelope and he had passed by like
a whisker
and
uh and so we got to go to his high
school graduation
and
you know i've been in high school and i
know how it works people applaud based
on how popular you are
uh when your name is called and
so my family had all come to his
graduation and i was telling everybody
you've got to like
cheer your brains out because we have to
be as loud as possible
and kathy was just saying oh i just i
don't care about that i just hope he
doesn't fall off the stage
and
they called his name
and the entire senior class came to
their feet applauding because they all
recognized
what he had overcome
in order to earn that diploma
kathy and i look at that experience as a
defining moment for us that was a moment
of healing it was a moment where we got
back
some of what we had lost and
peter still struggles
he had another defining moment where
just in an afternoon he lost his hearing
and
that happened recently
further isolated him
and
um
made his life harder made our lives
harder it's really hard to raise your
voice so that he can hear us
and not feel angry when you're shouting
it's
your body won't disconnect shouting and
anger and so we're always struggling
with like how do i talk loudly enough
for him to hear me
and not have to apologize for it
afterwards
we are not unique
in experiencing moments of loss
one of the things that experiencing loss
has sensitized us to
is that everyone
experiences losses
and often those losses happen out of
view
they're not
visible when we go to the grocery store
and
we believe it's true of our characters
as well
i think that
i think you can't work with characters
in this way without becoming more
compassionate
without becoming aware of what
people are suffering
and so in that way i i hope this book is
uh is a humanizing force within our
industry
and helps
people gain more compassion for one
another
and also for their characters and maybe
through their characters
even the audience will
will grow in the kind of compassion and
sensitivity and humanity
that
movies helped
to bring to me
our business could probably do with some
of that our world could probably do with
some of that
do you have a favorite chapter
you and kathy
definitely
i
you know i wrote
i wrote a book about script format a few
years ago
and
this is a very different kind of book
because so much of our heart is on the
page
i think probably the the chapter
that guides
the reader through discovering their own
defining moments is my favorite chapter
it's the chapter where we share
many of our own moments
sometimes you know big moments like the
brain tumor moment but also smaller
quieter moments that have also shaped us
we do that
as an encouragement
to
our readers
to be willing to look and find their own
defining moments and we also do it
as a way to model
what some of those moments look like and
how you might describe them
i think this book in some ways is
my response
to
seeing ordinary people
all those years ago
uh
experiencing a film that reached out
and made connection with me as a human
being
and this book is me reaching back out
into the world
to
connect in the way that
i was connected with to help
readers feel
less alone uh
but this is a very
specific group of readers these are
these are our filmmakers these are our
actors and writers and directors and
novelists these are the people who tell
stories in our time
so i consider it a massive privilege to
get to have a voice
helping to equip storytellers to tell
stories that
that will help connect us
was there any
story you
the two of you struggled to
maybe leave in or leave out was there
one that you felt whether i mean you
shared some incredibly personal stuff
just here and i think it could be
beneficial for so many people but
there's a risk you know right and and
that's
yeah
yeah i think that
uh kathy struggled
with how much to tell about
her relationship with her dad which was
not warm and close
um
he
he was a dad who never
ever said the words to her i love you
and she wants to honor her dad her dad
was a good man but he was not a warm man
and so she struggled with
whether to
put that story in her out of the book
and ultimately the stories in the book
she did it in a way that
was honoring to him
she actually drew on
what she words she said at his funeral
and
for me
i think speaking of
this moment that i can't remember
a moment that
seems to be of abuse in my early early
childhood
is
that was one that
i
hesitated to include
and wanted to be very
kind of
wise about how how i told that story
but it's also
one of the stories i'm most
interested in
sharing because i think it could be
somehow encouraging or beneficial uh to
someone else
and
i i think i found my way
to understanding that story
through
films and documentaries that i
identified with and i was i was feeling
really powerful emotions watching
documentaries in ways that didn't make
sense to me that i should be reacting
that way
and
watching those films ended up leading me
into
a
counseling dialogue
that
has like really helped me put my finger
on the lies
that had
had crippled me
and
allowed me then to figure out what was
actually true
so that's my hope is that in in sharing
these stories
um
stories become gifts that we give to
a reader to an audience
and stories work in a way that
is almost magical i can't explain how
stories work how each of us can hear the
same story read the same book watch the
same movie
and we connect with it in our in our own
way
we're moved by it in our own way we make
very personal application
so as we send these stories out into the
world i don't know
what
what will happen
but i'm hopeful and i look forward to
getting
some emails in return